leur sans précédent d'une immédiate
globalité depuis la création de notre
organisation il ya 75 ans et ce courage
ce fut d'abord celui de celles et ceux
qui ont été dès le premier jour en
première ligne partout dans le monde et
qu'ils le sont encore aujourd'hui pour
soigner nourrir accompagné épaules et
tenir nos soignants nos personnels
humanitaires
je veux en commençant ces quelques mots
penser à eux
ils attendent de nous que nous nous
engagions et que nous construisions des
réponses concrètes ensemble car cette
crise sans doute plus que tout aucune
autre impose la coopération impose
d'inventer de nouvelles solutions
internationales d'abord je crois en la
science et la connaissance et l'humanité
vaincre à cette pandémie un remède sera
trouvé mais dans cette attente dont nul
ne sait combien elles durent à chacun de
nos pays n'aura d'autre choix que
d'apprendre à vivre avec le virus et le
monde devra apprendre à vivre avec cette
nouvelle réalité qui s'impose à tous
révèlent nos vulnérabilités nous place
devant nos immédiate responsabilité
cette nouvelle réalité mondiale est
clair brutale certainement vertigineuse
et nous devons la regarder sans nous
laisser aller au désespoir ni au
découragement mais avec lucidité tous
les défis auxquels nous étions
confrontés ont été en quelques mois
accentuer et aggravait les succès
obtenus ont été entravés et les reculs
se sont accumulés des années de progrès
dans la lutte contre les autres maladies
infectieuses comme le vih le paludisme
la tuberculose dont nous pensions
pouvoir venir à bout ont pris du retard
parfois plus
plus de 37 millions de personnes sont
tombées ou retomber dans l'extrême
pauvreté l'insécurité alimentaire menace
gravement et s'est accrue plus d'un
milliard d'élèves ont été touchés par la
fermeture des écoles dans plus de 160
pays
40 millions d'enfants n'ont pas pu
bénéficier de la première année de leur
éducation
les femmes ont été en première ligne ont
vu s'accumuler contre elles toutes les
formes de violence sexuelle domestique
de genre face à cela et à tant d'autres
conséquences liées à la pandémie qui a
frappé notre planète et qui continuent
de toucher tous les continents
la fracturation de nos moyens d'action
collectif s'est accéléré alors même que
la seule solution viendra de notre
coopération
les organisations internationales dont
nous avons tant besoin comme
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ont
été accusés par les seins de
complaisance et instrumentalisé par les
autres les tiers de confiance
scientifiques journalistes si essentiel
pour comprendre et agir efficacement
face à la crise ont été remis en cause
par la propagande des états comme par
l'épidémie de la désinformation
notre organisation elle-même a couru le
risque de l'impuissance
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
garant de la paix de la stabilité est
difficilement parvenu à s'entendre sur
une trêve humanitaire que nous avons
soutenu de toutes nos forces
imaginez avoir tant de mal à nous
accorder sur sip
mais ses membres permanents n'ont pas pu
en des circonstances aussi exceptionnel
se réunir comme nous l'aurions voulu
parce que deux d'entre eux ont préféré à
l'efficacité collective l'affichage de
leur rivalité
toutes les fractures qui préexistait à
la pandémie
le choc hégémonique des puissances la
remise en cause du multilatéralisme son
instrumentalisation le piétinement du
droit international n'ont fait que
s'accélérer et s'approfondir à la faveur
de la déstabilisation globale crée par
la pandémie
nous n'avons plus le droit de fermer les
yeux
nous n'avons plus l'opportunité le luxe
si je puis dire de tergiverser cette
pandémie doit être pour notre
organisation un électrochoc et le moment
d'un réveil salvateur
c'est possible parce que dans cette
épreuve des motifs d'espérance sont
apparus l'union européenne dont beaucoup
quelque sorte prédisait la division et
l'impuissance à fait à la faveur de la
crise un pas historique d'unités de
souveraineté de solidarité de choix de
l'avenir c'est l'europe qui avec ses
partenaires africains a pris
l'initiative au g20 pour aider les pays
les plus vulnérables à faire face à la
pandémie et alléger le fardeau de la
dette qui pèse sur les économies et met
en péril l'avenir du continent pour la
première fois dans un g20 finances
nous avons acté d'un moratoire sur la
dette de ces pays les plus pauvres en
afrique c'est l'europe qui avec ses
partenaires a permis de construire
l'initiative acta pour que les moyens de
lutte contre la pandémie soit accessible
à tous c'est elle qui avec d'autres a
permis que l'assemblée mondiale de la
santé décide de tirer les leçons de la
pandémie et d'améliorer les systèmes
d'alerté de réaction précoce pour mieux
prévenir de telles crises c'est l'europe
qui avec d'autres partenaires en asie en
amérique en afrique a eu l'énergie de
construire de proposer de porter des
solutions concrètes de coopération de
solidarité et d'action il faudra compter
à l'avenir avec ces nouveaux équilibres
qui sont en train de se définir
il faudra compter sur la force des
bonnes volontés parce que le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui ne peut pas se
résumer à la rivalité entre la chine et
les états unis quel que soit le poids
mondial de ces deux grandes puissances
quel que soit aussi l'histoire qui nous
lie en particulier aux états unis
d'amérique la crise l'effondrement de
nos craintes de nos cadres de
coopération les fragilités que je viens
d'évoquer nous impose de rebâtir un
nouvel ordre et impose à l'europe de
prendre toute sa part de responsabilité
c'est à dire de porter ses valeurs son
goût de l'avenir et de savoir bâtir des
solutions nouvelles
parce que nous ne sommes pas
collectivement condamné à un pas de deux
qui en quelque sorte nous réduire et à
n'être que les spectateurs désolé d'une
impuissance collective
nous avons des marges de manoeuvre
à nous de les utiliser et à nous de
savoir définir les priorités qui sont
les nôtres dans cet environnement de
poser avec clarté nos choix et de
construire des alliances nouvelle dans
les semaines et les mois à venir des
choix fondamentaux seront à opérer des
décisions à prendre devant nos peuples
devant la communauté internationale
et ces choix auront un impact immédiat
sur la vie de nos nations sur
l'existence de nos concitoyens sur la
marche du monde
nous ne devons pas nous dérober parce
que c'est précisément quand tout vacille
qu'il faut revenir à l'essentiel et je
crois très profondément que depuis le
début de cette crise du coc u19 ce n'est
pas une parenthèse qui s'est ouverte et
se refermerait 7 la poursuite d'un monde
traversée par des crises profondes qui
sont aussi dues à nos interdépendances
et il y aura sûrement un jour un remède
à la pandémie
mais il n'y aura pas de remède miracle
la déstructuration de l'ordre
contemporain il n'y aura pas de remède
miracle à cette espèce de paradoxes dans
lequel nous sommes plongés jamais nos
sociétés n'ont été aussi
interdépendantes et au moment même où
tout cela arrive jamais nous n'avons été
si désaccordé si d aligner six incapable
de construire des solutions rapides
si en situation nous mêmes les mêmes
parfois de détruire les cadres de
coopération que nous avons su créé
durant les dernières décennies
c'est pourquoi je tenais à dire devant
cette assemblée les cinq priorités sur
lesquelles la france souhaite construire
avec ses partenaires européens au
premier chef mais avec aussi toutes les
puissances de bonne volonté c'est à dire
avec tous ceux qui seront prêts à s'y
engager les fondations d'un nouveau
consensus contemporain qui nous
permettra d'agir concrètement dans le
monde
le premier principe la première robe le
premier objectif c'est la lutte contre
la prolifération des armes de
destruction massive et contre le
terrorisme qui menace au premier chef
notre sécurité collective
la stratégie de la pression maximale
engagé depuis plusieurs années n'a pas
permis à ce stade de mettre fin aux
activités déstabilisatrices de l'iran ni
de nous assurer qu'il ne pourra pas se
doter de l'armé nucléaire
c'est pourquoi la france qui vous vous
en souvenez mais pas le pays qui a
initié à l'époque la négociation puis
consul à cordes discipline mais la
france avec ses partenaires allemands et
britanniques maintiendra son exigence de
mise en oeuvre pleine et entière de
l'accord de vienne de 2015 et
n'acceptera pas les violations commises
par l'iran
nous ne transigerons pas pour autant sur
l'activation d'un mécanisme que les
etats-unis de leur propre chef en
sortant de l'accord ne sont pas en
situation d'activer ce serait porter
atteinte à l'unité du conseil de
sécurité à l'intégrité de ses décisions
et ce serait prendre le risque
d'aggraver encore les tensions dans la
région mais il nous faut bâtir dans la
durée un cadre d'action utile que je
rappeler dans notre assemblée générale
même il y a maintenant plus de deux ans
c'est à dire la capacité à compléter
l'accord de 2015
d'abord dans le temps pour s'assurer que
dans la durée l'iran n'accédera jamais à
l'arme nucléaire mais aussi en assurant
que nous allons apporter les réponses à
l'activité balistiques de l'iran mais
aussi assez déstabilisation dans la
région sur la corée du nord
nous avons soutenu les efforts menés par
les états unis d'amérique pour permettre
l'engagement d'une négociation même si
les résultats tangibles ne sont pas
encore là ces initiatives étaient
importantes et ce que nous attendons à
présent ce sont des gestes d'engagement
concret de la part de la corée du nord
elle doit se conformer aux résolutions
du conseil de sécurité et s'engager
rapidement et de bonne foi dans un
processus de dénucléarisation complète
vérifiable et irréversible
c'est la seule voie possible pour
parvenir à une
solution politique à une paix durable
sur la péninsule coréenne
c'est incontournable pour la stabilité
et la sécurité régionales comme pour la
paix et la sécurité internationales de
la même manière nous ne tolérerons pas
que des armes chimiques soient employés
en europe en russie comme en syrie au
nom de la sécurité collective
je redis ici à la russie la nécessité
que toute la lumière soit faite sur la
tentative d'assassinât contre un
opposant politique à l'aide d'un agents
neurotoxiques le novice choc
cette clarification doit être rapide et
sans défaut car nous ferons respecter
nos lignes rouges
et en la matière la france a toujours
été au rendez-vous de l'effectivité des
lignes rouges fixées depuis que je suis
président de la république notre
sécurité collective c'est aussi la lutte
contre le terrorisme partout où cela est
nécessaire
la france a été touchée il y a plusieurs
années de manière répétée par le
terrorisme sur notre sol dans notre cher
avec des actes terroristes parfois
fomenté au coeur même à l'épicentre du
terrorisme islamiste je pense en
particulier aux attentats de 2015 conçu
en syrie c'est pourquoi la france sera
toujours fortement engagée au levant et
en appui à la souveraineté irakienne et
se tient aux côtés de ses partenaires
sails au levant nous continuerons d'être
engagée au sein de la coalition
internationale
nous avons eu une première victoire la
fin du califat territoriales cette
victoire ne marque pas la fin de la
guerre dans la région
nous continuerons de nous battre contre
tous les terroristes dans le cadre de la
coalition internationale et aux côtés de
thoune et part de tous nos partenaires
régionaux
je veux ici rappeler le rôle que les
combattants kurdes en syrie on tue aux
côtés de la coalition contre des ch et
les terroristes
je veux ici aussi rappelé le rôle
essentiel que l'irak et les irakiens ont
eu et continue d'avoir dans ce combat
c'est pourquoi la france soutient avec
force toutes les initiatives que l'irak
prend aujourd'hui continuera de prendre
pour sa souveraineté et son rôle dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme au sahel
la france est comme vous le savez
profondément engagés aux côtés
principalement des cinq états sahéliens
et les sommets de pau puis de nouakchott
ont permis de poser les bases d'une
coalition pour renforcer dans cette
région la lutte contre nos deux ennemis
l'état islamique et al qaïda
ces deux organisations ont subi au cours
des derniers mois des revers sans
précédent les objectifs fixés dépôt de
se concentrer sur la zone des trois
frontières et loïc gs ont produit des
résultats tangibles et inégalée jusqu'à
lors nous poursuivrons ce travail avec
l'appui de barkan et de nos partenaires
européens et américains les armes et du
g5 sahel ont repris l'aventage ont
réintégré des positions qui avaient été
perdues cette dynamique doit se
poursuivre
c'est le sens même de la coalition que
nous mettons en place ce qui vient de se
passer au mali au cours des dernières
semaines nous rappelle aussi une
évidence la démocratie et la lutte
contre le terrorisme vont de pair ces
deux combats ne sont pas séparables et
seule la démocratie la justice l'état de
droit le développement ramèneront une
paix durable au sahel
ce qu'ils ont fait irruption au mali au
nom de ces principes ne doivent pas
maintenant les trahir ils doivent mettre
le mali sur la voie irréversible du
retour à un pouvoir civil et
l'organisation d'élections rapides
la france comme ses partenaires
africains en particulier ne pourra
rester engagés qu'à cette condition
je le dis je leur dis très clairement la
france n'est présente sur le sol malien
comme sur le sol des autres pays de la
région qu'à la demande des états
souverains et des organisations
régionales à la seconde
c&a souhaiteront notre départ ou
considérant qu'ils peuvent se battre
seul contre le terrorisme nous nous
retirerons et c'est donc la réitération
de cette demande de ce besoin notre
engagement que j'ai demandé à pau puis à
nouakchott et qui a été aussi confirmée
par la junte au mali et c'est sur ce
sujet sur lequel nous resterons
extrêmement vigilant je crois dans la
souveraineté des peuples et je pense que
notre action contre le terrorisme ne
peut être utiles et durables que s'il se
conjugue avec le respect de sa
souveraineté
avec une démocratie effective et avec
une vraie politique de développement
celle aussi que nous avons conçu avec
l'alliance pour le sahel et qu'avec nos
partenaires européens africains avec la
banque mondiale aussi nous continuons de
développer pour des actions utiles sur
le terrain la deuxième priorité à mes
yeux des prochains mois c'est la
construction exigeante de la paix et de
la stabilité dans le respect de légal
souveraineté des peuples la grammaire de
la paix et de la stabilité est à
redéfinir parce que les lignes ont
profondément bouger à la faveur de la
crise nos fonds bien avant tel le
retrait américain qui faisait office de
garant en dernier ressort d'un système
international aujourd'hui dépassé
l'affirmation hégémonique d'autres
puissances à la faveur de ce
désengagement la projection de la chine
à l'extérieur de ses frontières
le renforcement de la souveraineté
européenne toutes ces tendances de fond
doivent nous conduire à repenser les
modalités de notre action collective
pour garantir la paix et la sécurité
le principe d'action à la matière
doivent être claires et notre main ne
doit plus tremblé dans leur application
le respect des droits souverains des
peuples la consolisation des états de
droit et de leurs moyens d'action
l'exigence et la responsabilité pour
assurer la mise en oeuvre effective des
décisions actées sous l'égide des
nations unies
c'est exactement ce que nous faisons au
liban où les aspirations du peuple
libanais souverain doivent être
respectés entendu et soutenu
quoi qu'il en soit des errements
inacceptable de la classe politique
libanaise
je veux ici redire tout mon soutien pour
le peuple libanais et ma détermination à
agir de là où je suis et en plein
respect de la souveraineté libanaise
mais en amitié exigences comme je dis
souvent pour que le liban puisse se
redresser pour que la vie puisse
s'améliorer et pour qu'aussi le chemin
d'un apaisement d'une démocratie plus
effective soit trouvée mais le liban est
un trésor pour l'humanité tout entière
un trésor parce qu'il est une forme
d'exception de démocratie et de
pluralisme dans une région
bousculé par le terrorisme et les
puissances hégémoniques
les nations unies doivent être
concrètement comme elles l'ont été cet
été et dans la durée
engagé aux côtés de la société civile et
des ong pour faire face aux besoins
immédiats et engager la reconstruction
est là aussi ne lâcheront rien
en syrie la reprise des pourparlers à
genève sous l'égide des nations unies
est une étape positive
mais ce processus ne peut se limiter à
la rédaction d'une nouvelle constitution
il devra passer par la tenue d'élections
libres régulières et transparentes pour
respecter là aussi les aspirations et la
souveraineté du peuple syrien
la france et ses partenaires européens
continueront donc de conditionner le
financement de la reconstruction et la
normalisation des relations avec damas à
la mise en oeuvre d'une solution
politique crédible la seule durable la
seule qui permettra d'éradiquer le
terrorisme dans la région
la paix au proche orient reste une
nécessité
d'abord pour les israéliens et les
palestiniens mais pour nous tous je me
réjouis qu israël obtiennent la
reconnaissance de nouveaux pays arabes
c'est une reconnaissance légitime c'est
aussi un gage d'espoir pour l'avenir
pour autant une paix juste et durable
nécessite avant tout de retrouver les
voies et moyens d'une négociation
décisive qui permette aux palestiniens
de disposer enfin de l'or
il n'y a pas d'alternative à une
négociation courageuse qui nécessitera
de s'entendre sur les questions les plus
difficiles dans le respect des
aspirations légitimes de chacun à une
reconnaissance pleine et entière à la
sécurité et à la souveraineté
je ne crois pas à une paix qui se
construira sur l'hégémonie ou
l'humiliation
quand bien même celles-ci seraient
compensés par de l'argent car nous
savons trop qu'on ne compense pas
l'humiliation d'un peuple par de
l'argent c'est à nous collectivement de
bâtir cette solution ambitieuse en libye
la crise a désormais un impact profond
sur la stabilité régionale et a été
aggravée par la multiplication des
ingérences extérieures
la libye est à mes yeux l'illustration
parfaite des erreurs auxquelles nous
pouvons conduire
nous pouvons nous même conduire
lorsqu'on ne respecte pas la
souveraineté des peuples
aucune puissance ne peut bâtir le bien
un peuple sans qu'il l'ait souhaitait et
construit lui même par les voix de
transition qu'il a souhaité aussi
aujourd'hui nous n'avons d'autre choix
que d'agir très concrètement c'est ce
que fait l'europe pour faire respecter
effectivement et par tous l'embargo sur
les armes décidé par les nations unies
cet embargo aujourd'hui et violée par
plusieurs puissances
cela n'est pas durable plusieurs
puissances aussi ont décidé de continuer
d'importer des combattants du théâtre
syrien exportant le terrorisme dans
cette région au mépris des intérêts de
la libye de ses voisins du sahel et de
l'europe nous avons été collectivement
trop silencieux sur ses agissements et
nous devons être beaucoup plus dur dans
les semaines qui viennent
nous travaillons avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires dont les pays voisins de la
libye pour obtenir un cessez le feu
durable puis enclencher une dynamique
qui permette une résolution politique du
conflit sous l'égide des nations unies
c'est l'initiative que la france
souhaite conduire dans les prochaines
semaines en lien avec le secrétaire
général des nations unies réunir
tous les pays voisins pour aider à faire
émerger la solution libyenne ce
réengagement du voisinage libyen est
indispensable dans la durée en
méditerranée orientale
il nous faut ré engager un dialogue
efficace et clarifier pour éviter un
nouvel espace de confrontation et de
remise en cause du droit international
les pays méditerranéens de l'union
européenne se sont exprimés clairement
en ce sens il ya quelques jours
ajaccio nous respectons la turquie nous
sommes prêts au dialogue avec elle mais
nous attendons qu'elle respecte la
souveraineté européenne le droit
international et apporte des
clarifications sur son action en libye
comme en syrie les insultes sont
inopérantes et toutes ces paroles et
tous ces actes n'ont pas leur place dans
des relations responsable entre état et
l'appel à la responsabilité que l'europe
a voulu lancer nous européens sommes
prêts au dialogue à la construction
indispensable d'une pax méditerranéen
mais pas au prix de l'intimidation pas
au prix de la logique du plus fort dans
le respect du droit international de la
coopération et du respect entre alliés
ces principes sont non négociables en
europe continentale sur la crise
ukrainienne le format normandie nous a
permis cette année avec la chancelière
fédérale d'allemagne d'obtenir deux
premières avancées mais la situation en
biélorussie comporte le risque d'une
nouvelle fracture sur notre continent
le courage du peuple biélorusse force
l'admiration de tous ses aspirations
doivent être respectées et nous sommes à
ses côtés je veux le dire avec beaucoup
de force
un dialogue politique national doit être
mise en place et toute intervention
extérieure doit être évité nous avons
l'occasion avec la chancelière
d'allemagne avec le président du conseil
d'échanger avec le président poutine
et de plaider pour une médiation
proposée par le sca ne voyons pas
d'autre chemin que celui ci
non à l'ingérence non silence coupable
l'europe là aussi sera au rendez vous de
sa responsabilité de son histoire et de
sa géographie
mais croire à la paix et à la stabilité
dans notre région c'est aussi vouloir
bâtir pour l'europe continentale les
nouvelle grammaire en quelque sorte
d'une stabilité durable et celle ci ne
saurait se réduire
ni aux accords historiques ni au fond au
démantèlement de ces accords durant les
dernières années lorsqu'on parle de paix
de stabilité de sécurité collectif pour
l'europe
je ne peux pas taire aujourd'hui le fait
que nous vivons dans une situation notre
sécurité et stabilité dépend des très
largement d'accord signé jadis entre les
états unis d'amérique et lurs et que ces
accords ont progressivement été
démantelé durant la dernière décennie la
fin du traité et fait ni amara a marqué
une étape importante sur laquelle nous
ne devons rester silencieux c'est
pourquoi je souhaite que nous européens
puissions réengager le cadre d'une
discussion complète et ambitieuse avec
tous nos voisins pour notre sécurité
collective et construire le cadre
nouveau qui prenne en compte la fin de
ces traités historiques
je le dis aussi avec beaucoup de cartes
et nous ne délivrons pas notre sécurité
collective à d'autres puissances
calories troisièmement nous devons
protéger les biens qui nous sont communs
c'est notre responsabilité à tous cela
va au delà nos intérêts nationaux de nos
équilibres régionaux protéger nos biens
communs n'est pas contradictoire avec
l'exercice de notre souveraineté
c'est au contraire la seule manière de
la préserver réellement en gardant le
contrôle de nos destins c'est exactement
ce que la crise que nous traversons
démontre une fois de plus de manière
incontestable la santé d'un seul face à
une épidémie c'est la santé de tous et
nous avons une occasion unique de faire
des moyens de lutte contre la pandémie
des biens publics mondiaux auxquels
chacun devra avoir accès
c'est le sens de l'action que nous
conduisons dans le cadre d'actes à et
nous que nous consoliderons dans les
prochains mois sur l'ensemble des
piliers notamment sur le renforcement
des systèmes de santé la santé bien
public mondial
c'est un combat que nous avons mené
durant toute l'année qui vient de
s'écouler que nous avions mené aussi à
lyon quand il s'est agi de remobiliser
la communauté internationale pour
financer la lutte contre ces aides des
épidémies historique
c'est ce que nous continuerons de faire
et nous devons lui donner plus de force
dans les mois qui viennent le climat et
la biodiversité doivent être plus que
jamais aussi au coeur de notre agenda
collectif pas dans les mots mais dans
les actes en décembre l'accord de paris
aura cinq ans et nous savons d'ores et
déjà que les objectifs que nous nous
étions collectivement fixe et ne
pourront pas être atteints
la réponse à la pandémie peut changer la
donne les plans de relance massifs
adoptés dans tous les pays sont une
occasion historique de transformation de
nos modèles économiques et de
développement
cela doit être au coeur de l'ambition de
l'union européenne et je remercie la
présidente de la commission qui s'est
fortement engagée
cela doit être au coeur des travaux du
g7 et du g20
c'est indispensable c'est aussi pour
cela que je veux que la france puisse le
jour anniversaire des cinq ans d'accord
de paris mobiliser à nouveau la
communauté internationale afin chacune
et chacun d'entre nous de regarder où
nous en sommes nos engagements sans en
changer en quelque sorte la mesure sont
brouiller les cartes
mais en remobilisant très fortement
l'ensemble de nos pays et de nos régions
dans une transparence complète mais dans
un volontarisme qu'il faut renouveler
l'europe parviendra dans les prochaines
semaines j'y suis déterminé à un accord
pour réhausser le niveau de son ambition
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone en
la présidente de la commission
européenne a fixé l'objectif de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre à au moins 55 % en 2030
cela suppose d'aller plus vite
plus fort sur un e ts ambitieux un prix
du carbone minimum un mécanisme
d'inclusion carbone aux frontières
l'ensemble de ces mesures constituent un
tout l'une sans les autres n'auraient
pas la même efficacité aux côtés de nos
partenaires britanniques et européens
nous irons chercher sur cette base un
par un les engagements des grands
émetteurs en vue de la coop 26 et nous
serons aux côtés de nos partenaires
notamment africains pour atteindre nos
objectifs communs
le rendez-vous de descendre sur ce
chemin sera essentielle en novembre nous
réunirons à paris un sommet des banques
de développement pour faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des flux financiers
contribuer à une relance écologique et
solidaire en ligne avec l'accord de
paris sur la biodiversité dont les liens
avec le changement climatique comme la
santé humaine sont désormais établies
nous organiserons dans les prochains
mois à marseille avec les nations unies
avec la banque mondiale
un one planet ce mythe qui nous
permettra de bâtir un agenda d'actions
concrètes sur les aires protégées
terrestres et marines l'agroécologie le
financement de la biodiversité et la
lutte contre la déforestation la
protection aussi des écosystèmes et des
espèces les océans l'épaule
les forêts tropicales appartiennent au
patrimoine commun de l'humanité nous
devons les protéger et nous le ferons en
vue des échéances décisives que seront
pour les nations unies
les coptes climat biodiversité et lutte
contre la désertification pour être au
rendez vous je vous propose qu'un sommet
soit organisée l'an prochain à new york
en amont de ces trois coop pour leur
donner une impulsion décisive et aboutir
à des résultats tangibles
l'espace numérique est aussi un bien
commun un bien commun unique ouvert et
de confiance qui doit faire l'objet
d'une gouvernance nouvelle pour éviter
qu'ils ne soient captés pirate est
instrumentalisée c'est le sens des
initiatives que nous portons dans le
cadre du partenariat informations et
démocratie de l'appel de christchurch
ainsi que du partenariat mondial sur
l'intelligence artificielle
nous devons consolider chacun de ces
partenariats avancé aussi sur le
processus d'aqaba et je remercie
l'engagement d'un premier ministre néo
zélandaise comme du roi de jordanie sur
cet agenda
ce sont maintenant des solutions
concrètes mais surtout maintenant nous
avons besoin pas simplement des
engagements des actions des grands
opérateurs des actions des grandes
plateformes et d'un engagement de notre
part à tous à légiférer à réglementer au
niveau de nos régions
s'ils ne sont pas au rendez vous des
engagements pris la lutte contre la
haine la lutte contre le terrorisme la
création au fond d'un ordre public
commun de l'internet sont aussi
importants que l'innovation
technologique et que la liberté car il
n'y a pas de liberté sans ordre public
c'est à nous de le créer par un
engagement international et je ne crois
pas que la protection de la liberté
d'expression puisse s'accomoder du
discours terroristes des discours de
haine de l'anonymat qui couvre en
quelque sorte la désinhibition de la
violence cet agenda est essentiel pour
nous tous et toutes nous continuerons
d'y agir avec force
enfin et je le dis dans un contexte qui
est celui de l'épidémie que je rappelais
l'éducation est un bien commun essentiel
sur lequel nous continuerons nous
engager dans l'année qui vient
des centaines de millions de nos jeunes
n'ont été sortie de l'éducation à cause
de l'épidémie
mais l'éducation en particulier
l'éducation des jeunes filles continuent
d'être une priorité tout
particulièrement en afrique
aux côtés du président macky sall nous
nous sommes engagés pour le partenariat
mondial pour l'éducation
nous avons levé des fonds nouveaux afin
de financer les actions de ce
partenariat le rôle aujourd'hui de la
banque mondiale des nations unies du
partenariat mondial pour l'éducation de
l'unesco
le rôle aussi de nos actions bilatérales
doivent être renforcées afin d'agir plus
efficacement encore dans les mois et les
années qui viennent pour améliorer
l'éducation et tout particulièrement
l'éducation des jeunes filles
ce combat n'est pas terminé loin de là
et nous ne saurions l'oublier il est au
coeur en tout cas de l'engagement
français en matière de défense et de
lutte pour les biens publics mondiaux
la quatrième priorité c'est la
construction d'une nouvelle ère de la
mondialisation
la première ère de la mondialisation fut
ouverte par les voyage de christophe
colomb de magellan celle de la
découverte des premières invasions aussi
d'un tâtonnement en quelque sorte d'une
forme de fascination ou parfois de
malentendus réciproque
la seconde fut celle des empires
coloniaux et de la révolution
industrielle du 19e siècle ce fut la
mondialisation par le commerce
les premières ouvertures mais aussi les
routes de l' esclavage de l'exploitation
et du développement des seins de
l'asservissement des autres des premiers
déplacements de population et d'une
recomposition de notre monde à l'aune de
ces domination la troisième a commencé
en 1989 avec la chute du mur de berlin
l'ouverture des frontières la croix cyan
la croyance en la possibilité que la
circulation des biens et des personnes
puis la généralisation de l'internet
conduisent à des convergences d'intérêts
de valeur d'idées au fond c'est en cette
ère de la mondialisation
je passe là en cavalcade on pourrait
séparer chacune de ces aires en bien
d'autres période mais c'est cette
troisième ère qui a été remise en cause
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années à
ce que la conviction profonde la
téléologie qui l'accompagnait c'était
que cette mondialisation sur une
modélisation de la paix un rapprochement
des valeurs une universalisation du
respect de l'autre et elle a été remise
en cause par la crise financière les
transformations du monde
le retour des peuples
des consciences nationales et enfin la
pandémie mondiale
remise en cause aussi par une crise
profonde la crise des classes moyennes
occidentales qui à un moment ont douté
de ce que cet ordre nouveau de ce que
certains avaient pu appeler cette
mondialisation heureuse pouvait le
rappeler ces classes moyennes qui
partout en occident souvent été les
variables d'ajustement économique vie
culturelle de ce monde ainsi ouvert
alors ils seraient infondées en quelque
sorte de deniers tout ce que cette
période a permis de faire d'avancé tout
ce que cette troisième ère de la
mondialisation a permis d'apporter en
termes de prospérité elle a sorti des
centaines de millions de personnes de la
grande pauvreté précisément par une
redistribution du commerce et de la
production mondiale et l'ouverture a
permis une prise de conscience des
voyages des circulations qui ont aussi
pacifié pour partie une relation et il
serait dangereux de nous enfermer dans
un bégaiement de l'histoire dans un
protectionnisme généralisé à coups de
droits de douane de guerre commerciale
dans une espèce de doute qui nous
conduirait au renfermement où est la
logique des puissances parce qu'on le
voit bien le risque c'est de répondre à
cette crise de la mondialisation par un
repli nationaliste par la violence des
populismes des extrêmes plus tôt et par
le retour des puissances mais il est
clair que les chaînes de valeur
mondiales doivent être aujourd'hui
repenser parce que la crise a démontré
que la dépendance sur des secteurs
stratégiques tels que la santé le
numérique l'intelligence artificielle
l'alimentation aussi peuvent remettre en
question dans le monde tel qu'il est le
libre exercice de la souveraineté mais
nous avons aussi vu qu' il y a des
bonnes dépendance
il ya des dépendances qui nous fragilise
nous avons besoin de garder le commerce
international et les ouvertures parce
que c'est bon pour nous sur le plan
économique et social parce que nous ne
saurions d'ailleurs tout ré internaliser
parce que cela conduit à des justes
dépendance qui impose la coopération
mais la dépendance complète à l'égard de
certaines puissances qu'elles soient
technologiques qu'elle soit alimentaire
ou industriels créent des vulnérabilités
qui ne permet plus les équilibres qui
vont avec l'ordre du monde
ensuite les inégalités de ce nouvel
ordre mondial sont devenues
insoutenables
nous avons sorti des 1000 des centaines
de millions de personnes de la grande
pauvreté dans certains pays nous avons
réduit pour partie des inégalités
nord-sud mais nous avons creusé les
inégalités au sein de pays et ce nouvel
ordre rend insoutenable démocratiquement
le cours des choses tel qu'il va puis
nous avons créé une mode et de nous
mondialisation des consciences qui est
aujourd'hui une mondialisation en
quelque sorte non plus du savoir qui
était le sous jacent d'internet mais qui
est devenue une mondialisation de
l'émotion et du ressentiment sur chacune
de ces crises nous devons apporter une
réponse c'est cette stratégie dans
l'union européenne est en train de se
doter comme d'autres puissances il est
impératif que nos règles internationales
soit adapté pour tenir compte de ces
nouvelles réalités nous doter des moyens
d'une coopération internationale plus
équilibrée qui se fasse dans le respect
la souveraineté de chacun au bénéfice de
tous à cet égard la lutte contre les
inégalités devra être très clairement au
coeur de cette mondialisation repenser
la france apporté des initiatives qui
ont permis des résultats sur
l'entrepreneuriat féminin sur le
partenariat mondial pour l'éducation sur
la santé pour tous pour lutter contre
toutes les inégalités de destin mais il
faudra aller plus loin en quelque sorte
vous le voyez bien ce monde dans lequel
nous avons vécu reposer sur une un
consensus académique devenu un consensus
politique et de marché ce qu'on a
souvent appelé le consensus de
washington il a vécu nous devons reposer
ensemble les bases d'une mondialisation
plus juste plus équilibrée plus
équitable plus durable nous devons
penser les termes d'une mondialisation
qui accepte de revenir et de repenser
les termes d'une juste souveraineté et
du juste échange qui intègre en son sein
au coeur de son modèle la lutte contre
les inégalités sous toutes leurs formes
qu'elle soit
de genre de conditions ou économique la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
et pour la biodiversité et qui
permettent de manière durable d'intégrer
les conditions d'un nouvel équilibre du
monde nous aurons là aussi apporter des
propositions concrètes dans quelques
semaines au forum de paris et le travail
engagé avec la commission européenne
avec le fonds monétaire international et
beaucoup d'autres puissances de bonne
volonté sera essentiel à cet égard
l'afrique sera avec l'europe le moteur
de cette redéfinition des termes de la
mondialisation
c'est pourquoi nous continuerons nos
efforts dans le cadre de l'initiative
que nous avons construite pour aider les
pays africains à faire face à la
pandémie sur le plan sanitaire
économique social et humanitaire
le g20 de novembre sera un rendez vous
décisif pour la mise en oeuvre du
moratoire sur la dette que nous avons
acté et pour aller plus loin nous devons
aussi mieux accompagner les immenses
énergie des sociétés civiles de cette
jeunesse du continent qui est sa force
et son avenir c'est le sens des
initiatives que nous porterons dans les
prochains mois avec les diasporas et en
soutien au secteur privé africain
enfin le cinquième objectif que je veux
ici seuil est de proposer à notre
collectif c'est le respect du droit
international humanitaire et des droits
fondamentaux de chacun pour moi cet
objectif est essentiel à la survie même
de notre organisation
en effet nous assistons dans ce domaine
à une série de reculs bien souvent trop
de silence depuis la création par les
nations unies d'une journée mondiale
humanitaire cinq mille travailleurs ont
été victimes d' attaque 18 cents ont été
assassinés l'année dernière a été la
plus meurtrière et j'ai une pensée toute
particulière pour ces jeunes françaises
et français qui au sein de
l'organisation acte ait de vraies
exactement dans ce cadre au niger
et ont été tués dans des conditions
atroces mois d'août dernier
non les nations unies ne peuvent pas
rester inactive devant une telle
régression
c'est pourquoi avec les ong françaises
avec nos partenaires internationaux nous
construisons une initiative pour assurer
l'effectivité du droit international la
protection du personnel humanitaire et
la lutte contre l'impunité
l'espace humanitaire est un patrimoine
commun qu'il nous faut protéger en
garantissant l'accès aux populations
civiles comme la protection des
personnels qui les soutiennent nous
avons vu des reculs sur ce sujet
inexcusable
nous avons vu des pratiques y compris de
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité en syrie en particulier
inacceptable
la neutralité de l'action humanitaire
doit être respectée et sa
criminalisation endiguer prendre nos
responsabilités dans le domaine
humanitaire
c'est aussi faire preuve de solidarité
et d'humanité dans le domaine migratoire
la situation en grèce amoria est
aujourd'hui très difficile la france aux
côtés de l'allemagne et de ses
partenaires prendra ses responsabilités
pour accueillir les réfugiés et nous
devons agir tous ensemble dans la
gestion des flux migratoires pour mettre
fin au trafic d'êtres humains aux
traversées de la mort aux routes de la
nécessité ce sera au coeur de l'agenda
européen des prochaines semaines j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
nous devons intensifier la lutte contre
ces trafiquants et être au rendez vous
nos responsabilités enfin les droits
fondamentaux ne sont pas une idée
occidentale que l'on pourrait opposer
comme une ingérence à tous ceux qui s'y
réfèrent ce sont des principes de notre
organisation inscrits dans des textes
que les états membres des nations unies
ont librement consenti à signer et à
respecter
c'est la raison pour laquelle notamment
la france a demandé qu'une mission
internationale sous l'égide des nations
unies puissent se rendre au xing zhang
afin de prendre en compte les
préoccupations que nous avons
collectivement sur la situation de la
minorité musulmane ouïghoure
et c'est parce que nous ne pouvons pas
tolérer que 25 ans après la conférence
de pékin les droits des femmes dans le
monde connaisse un profond recul que
nous organiserons
l'été prochain le forum génération
égalité avec onu femmes avec la société
civile pour l'émancipation de toutes
l'éducation des filles et le respect
réel et effectif des droits de l'homme
voilà les cinq principes sur lesquels la
france veut reconstruire avec vous les
fondements de l'ordre international pour
que les fondements de notre organisation
ne soit pas emporter par la pandémie
au contraire il faut prendre le
changement par la main avant qu'il ne
nous prennent par la gorge disait
winston churchill
cela nécessite en méthode
l'établissement d'une coopération
internationale fonctionnel fondé sur des
règles claires défini et respecté par
tous le multilatéralisme n'est pas
seulement un acte de foi
c'est une nécessité opérationnel aucun
pays ne se sortira seul de cette épreuve
la coopération internationale peut être
difficile mais elle est objectivement
impérative pour autant nous ne pouvons
plus nous contenter d'un
multilatéralisme des mots qui me permet
de d'agréer que le au fond le plus grand
dénominateur commun manière de masquer
des divergences profondes sous un
consensus de façade
il faut changer de méthode inverser les
termes du contrat être aussi haut et
clair quand certains se piquent
d'adhérer à des alliances et à leurs
principes à des organisations à leurs
principes pour les foulées aux pieds
aurel soyons honnêtes entre nous lucide
exigeant le multilatéralisme
contemporain doit aussi associer les
organisations internationales les
acteurs privés des entreprises les ong
les chercheurs les citoyens pour que
chacun soit partie prenante des actions
engagées
il se construira sur la base d'accords
solide respecter vérifier entre
partenaires de bonne foi autour
d'objectifs et de règles claires avec
une vraie responsabilité et des
mécanismes de redevabilité c'est
pourquoi au forum de paris pour la paix
en novembre
nous nous efforcerons avec nos
partenaires européens et africains avec
tous ceux qui le souhaitent en asie en
amérique et ailleurs de consolider les
bases de ce nouveau consensus
international
au bénéfice de l'avenir de notre
organisation je ne crois pas au grand
jour de refondation je crois en un
travail déterminé méthodique rigoureux
de construction d'un ordre international
contemporain qui permettra de tenir les
générations futures à l'écart du fléau
de la guerre d'affirmer les droits de
l'homme et l'égalité entre les nations
de favoriser le progrès social dans une
liberté plus grande
c'est la promesse même de notre charte
elle est d'actualité
je crois en la force de la volonté en la
valeur de la sincérité et du courage et
en vous parlant en ce moment même malgré
la distance que crée l'écran et j'ai en
mémoire le regard d'une enfant libanaise
rencontré il ya quelques jours qu'ils
avaient tout perdu tout perdu mais qui
avait fait le serment de se battre
envers et contre tout pour ce en quoi
elle croit
c'est la même mémoire pour les jeunes
français assassinés au niger parce
qu'ils croyaient en un monde d'humanité
de solidarité et de fraternité mais
c'est le même souvenir que beaucoup
d'entre vous ont sûrement et doivent
savoir qu'ils nous obligent qui nous
oblige à agir et qui nous interdit le
cynisme qui nous oblige qui nous oblige
à agir et qui nous interdit le
découragement ou la facilité il y a des
vies mais il ya surtout des jeunes
filles des jeunes garçons qui partout
dans le monde s'engage parce qu'ils
croient à nos maux parce qu'ils vivent
pour et par nos principes
si nous les trahit son nous sommes les
premiers coupables de leur désillusion
ou du fait qu'il perde tout alors c'est
à nous de faire
je nous sens est capable en tout cas là
où nous sommes
nous ferons tout pour agir et je sais
que beaucoup de collègues ils sont pris
aussi je compte sur chacune et chacun
d'entre vous merci
en billard au nom de l'assemblée
générale je remercie le président la
réplique française de sa déclaration
nous venons d'entendre le dernier
orateur inscrit sur la liste pour cette
séance du débat général